[Music]
morning all
uh dozens of people remain missing this
morning and rivers and lakes
dangerously high after severe flooding
across parts of europe
the latest figures have just arrived 92
people
are now known to have died in germany
and belgium after swollen rivers caused
a wave of debris through towns and
villages
at six people are missing in turkey and
in switzerland lake lucerne
is close to bursting its banks germany's
chancellor angela merkel has called it
a catastrophe or one of the worst
affected areas
is the village of shuld in western
germany where a row of houses collapsed
are you from there our europe
correspondent michelle clifford reports
in western germany the army had been
brought in to deal with the aftermath of
the devastating floods
residents in hagen forced to flee their
homes after the river vol
burst its banks
oh my god the sheer force of the floods
swept away anything in their path
in altena locals watched on unable to do
anything as flood waters stream down
their streets
the village of sheldon is among the
hardest hit several homes have collapsed
here
and the village is among many with no
power and very difficult to access
overnight they were upstairs and it was
dark because there was no
um no light no no
power chancellor angela merkel on a
farewell visit to joe biden in
washington
describe the situation as a catastrophe
i grieve for those who have lost their
lives in this disaster
we still don't know the number but it
will be many
some in the basements of their homes
some as firefighters were trying to
bring others to safety
and to their loved ones my deepest
sympathies
anthony
across europe record rainfall has caused
some of the worst flooding in decades
in eastern belgium rivers burst their
banks and cascaded through towns and
cities
homes and livelihoods destroyed in an
instant
luckily i have my sister but now we've
been told that our house could collapse
and so we've had to leave
it
in pepinster some residents had to be
rescued on the back of trucks
much of the town of valkenburg in
southeast netherlands
has been left underwater too homes and
business is inundated
and the fear remains of more rain in the
coming days
in turkey a major rescue operation is
underway
after flash floods and landslides in the
black sea province of riese
authorities say many villages are cut
off and impossible to reach
and the swiss city of lucerne is on high
alert with its lake just centimeters
from bursting its banks
sandbags and inflatable flood barriers
are being put in place
as the water continues to rise
the reason for the installation of the
inflatable flood barriers
was that some forecasts said that the
lake level is going to continue to rise
and that the magic limit will be reached
in many parts of western germany rescue
services are still
searching for those missing feared swept
away by the floods
and the rescue work continues as the
rain keeps falling
michelle clifford sky news germany
now england's chief medical officer has
warned that we could
get into trouble again surprisingly fast
in the fight against covet 19.
uh professor witty one of the prime
minister's main advisers
was speaking during a live stream event
just days before restrictions in
england are relaxed we are not by any
means out of this
the woods yet on this in much better
shape due to the vaccine program
and drugs and a variety of other things
but this has got a long way to run
in the uk and it's got even further to
run globally what we really need to do
all of us is take things incredibly
slowly i would i would reiterate that
now
but i don't think we should
underestimate the fact that
we could get into trouble again
surprisingly fast
and joining us now on the programme lucy
fraser solicitor general for england and
wales ms fraser very good morning to you
good morning um given that which we just
heard from
professor witty given the infection
rates given the hospitalization rates
are you still
comfortable with the great unlocking
that is coming on monday
well you're right that infection rates
are still rising but
the situation we're in at the moment is
that around 80 percent of people have
had their first vaccine
and over two-thirds have had their
second vaccine
and we know that we have weakened the
link between the infection rates
the hospitalizations and deaths and so
now is a good time to loosen those
those restrictions because if we don't
do it now when are we going to do it
well perhaps in a in a few weeks time
when more people have been vaccinated
well we did wait you will remember we
did we were meant to be opening up on
june the 21st but
uh the government made the decision to
delay that to enable more people to be
vaccinated
and we are we've beaten uh the target
that we set
uh for those second vaccinations by a
week
uh and so now we are moving uh from
legal restrictions
to people taking personal responsibility
uh so when
we are saying to people do continue to
be cautious do take measures
uh but now we are just taking away those
legal restrictions
because of the success of the vaccine
program but
let's just dwell just for a second on
that which we heard from you know none
other than the
chief medical officer chris whitty said
this i don't think we should
underestimate the fact that we could get
into trouble again surprisingly fast
things could look a lot worse in five
six seven eight weeks time that's the
chief medical officer
saying in essence that in a little over
a month we could see restrictions coming
back in
isn't it well he did say
um that matters could escalate and of
course
that is true but he also said let's look
at how
where we have uh come from and let's
look at uh also
that we're not in the same place that we
were when restrictions
uh first went in we have the vaccination
program
we have the genomic sequencing to detect
new strains we have the test and trace
system we are uh fully uh
stocked with pp and all those other
things that we just didn't have
when restrictions came came in place and
the key to all this uh has been the
vaccination program because we know that
you're
much less likely to get a severe illness
uh if you are double vaccinated sure but
i'll repeat the question
chris whittie saying you know when five
six seven eight weeks time we
we may need to look at things again that
is the chief medical officer saying
that in england with in a little over a
month we could see a return to
restrictions isn't it
well i think the health secretary has
been very clear as has the prime
minister that we will
see infections rise um but the reason
why the restrictions are being taken
away
is because of the vaccination program
which will protect people when those
infection rates do rise and of course if
we get into a situ
situation where it's unacceptable um
and we do need to put back further
restrictions then
that of course is something the
government will look at
but you know we're going into the summer
a large number of people have been
vaccinated
and we've had a really tough time we're
still asking people to take
responsibility
and we do need to ask ourselves if we
don't open up now when will we
will we be able to open up yep as you
say mr fraser we are asking people to
to do you exercise their own judgment
we're asking people to go slowly but
we've got 140 000 people pitching up at
silverstone this weekend
well there are some large events and of
course there are measures in relation
to those large events but what i've seen
over the course of the last year
is people taking a huge amount of
personal responsibility
and not always um just abiding by the
rules but going
beyond the rules i've seen people you
know outsider wearing masks
where they don't have to and and there
are
different restrictions uh in different
places for different reasons and
of course the measures uh will be
changing um on next monday
i i just wonder if we can dwell just for
a moment on on the the the covered up
the
the nhs app pinged 520 194 people
in the week leading up to to july the
7th that's not sustainable is it we're
already beginning to see businesses
complaining about the fact that
production lines are in essence
literally grinding to a halt
well i understand people's frustration
in relation to that but we must remember
it is an important tool the
self-isolation tool
and but we have already announced of
course that on august the 16th
again the measures will change and if
you are fully vaccinated
you won't have to isolate but instead
take a test
sure but that is a that is a month away
and we're not yet even at as
as ministers have stopped calling it we
used to freedom day we're four days away
from monday the only thing that is going
to happen when we relax restrictions is
that more
people will be getting pinged five
hundred thousand in the week to july the
seventh
one wonders what it's going to be in a
couple of weeks time perhaps reaching
into the millions
uh well as i said it is an important
tool because it is important that you do
isolate if you've
come into contact i know this is
something the government is looking at
in addition to the changes uh in
mid-august the government is always also
carrying out a number of pilots
to see whether instead of isolating once
you get pinged
you could take a test so the government
is looking at this uh very
very carefully recognizing the
significant impact
that is having on businesses
medical experts in the british medical
journal have been have been pretty
scathing about the plans for the july
the 19th they've claimed that the
government's strategy of
as they describe infection over
vaccination unethical
and unscientific
i just wonder if you have a response to
the bmj describing the government's
strategy as
again unethical and unscientific
well the the government acts uh basing
its decisions its political decisions
based on scientific evidence and what
it's seen
uh in this period uh coming up to july
the 19th is that although infection
rates
are rising the link between infections
hospitalizations and death is weakening
so if i if i give you
um some recent statistics um we
recently i i believe this is yesterday
uh but the numbers might be
slightly off that we had around 40 000
infections we had around 500
hospitalizations
and around 50 deaths so there is of
course all those hospitalizations
uh are of concern and even more so the
deaths but there is a significant
difference
between the number of infections uh and
the translation into
hospitalizations and deaths well
actually i mean
you are correct i mean the figures have
changed slightly from that rather than
40
000 it was almost 50 000 new cases
yesterday the high since january the
15th
rather than 500 hospital admissions as
you said it was 621.
we've got 3241 beds occupied compared
with 2209 last wednesday
things are getting bad very very quickly
as chris whittie said
i don't think that the health secretary
has
suggested anything otherwise then the
infection rate is going to rise
and as a consequence of the infection
rate rising
that means because there is a link
between the two
that it follows that hospitalizations
and deaths
will rise as well but there are also
consequences
to not opening up real consequences
not just to people's jobs and the
economy but to mental health as well
also to people who haven't been going to
the doctor
because they fear it there is a we
and so it is really important that we
get the balance
right between ensuring that we keep this
virus
under control and we take the necessary
clinical measures to do that
but that we also recognize there are
consequences
of not opening up and not allowing
people uh to go about
their their daily lives uh mr we do
appreciate you taking so much time to
speak on stuff that is technically away
from your brief i just wonder if we can
move it slightly closer to it um
the statute of limitations that is being
uh introduced
uh to deal with uh prosecutions relating
to actions during the troubles in
northern ireland
all five political parties in northern
ireland are opposed to this the irish
government as opposed to this
provisionals on both sides are opposed
to this is it time for a rethink
so the the issue in relation to this is
that as time moves on
the chances of getting uh prosecution
successful convictions
um gets lower and i know that this issue
is causing um a lot of um
a lot of issues uh in in in ireland
and and it is important that we get
engaged on this subject
uh and the rifts are developing and i
know that the government
is engaging with all parties i will
continue to do so
uh before it brings forward any
legislation
lucy fraser great to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with us
this morning thanks very much thank you
still to come this morning at half past
i'll be speaking to adam finn
a member of the joint committee on
vaccinating vaccination and
immunization on the rollouts of this
year's flu vaccine
[Music]
can you help research how climate change
has affected butterflies
in britain at conservation expert dr zoe
randall joins us at quarter 2 to talk
about the big butterfly kind
[Music]
and at half past eight we'll be speaking
to a club owner ahead of the reopening
of
england's nightclubs on monday
now rape victims are being denied
justice because of a blame culture
between police and prosecutors according
to a report
from official inspectors it says there's
deep division and finger pointing
between the different agencies well the
crime prosecution service estimates that
there are
128 000 victims of rape and attempted
rape a year but as you can see
only 1.6 of reported cases result in a
charge
figures for 20 1920 show 1 439
suspects were convicted of rape or
lesser infancies
in england and wales last year it is the
lowest level since records began despite
reports
of adult rape to police almost doubling
since 2015-16
our correspondent ivor bennett joins us
now from the newsroom
i have a distressing report yeah
absolutely
uh a damning indictment even of the way
rape cases are handled and it was done
by the watchdogs for policing and
prosecution
and they found that there is tension
basically between those two
agencies with one each one blaming the
other for those
astonishingly low conviction rates it
also found that there is
uh what it called the more cautious
attitude when it comes to investigating
and prosecuting rape compared to other
alleged offences and all of this
means that the response from the
criminal justice system as a whole
it says often lacks focus clarity and
commitment
it doesn't much work sorry i i i think
you might need to hit your microphone
with a hammer there's a problem with
this sound we'll come back to you and
discuss a little bit more
later on today uh but let's bring you a
few of the other
stories of the morning several people
have been injured after a tornado
hit parts of the canadian province of
ontario the city of barry was worst
affected
and officials say four people have been
seriously injured
several buildings are said to have been
destroyed with many others left
uninhabitable
the government will today reveal how the
flu jab will be rolled out alongside
a possible covert booster many experts
fear that there could be formal cases of
flu this winter
because so many people have stayed away
from crowdy places during lockdown
it is a week until the opening of the
delayed 2020 olympics
and we're being told to expect a very
different sort of games in japan
tokyo is under a state of emergency
following an increase in coronavirus
cases
hitting a six-month high in fact our
sports correspondent tom parmenter
reports
this is their games karate making its
debut
japan hosting the world
but rather than celebrating the back of
the pandemic
tokyo is still fighting it
and it's already snatched away their
chance to take part
i'm so sad
tonight welcome to japan
home to the world's biggest experiment
in the time of a pandemic
there's pre-departure tests tracking
apps paperwork saliva tests
it's a good safety net but it can never
be perfect
and the japanese know it their recovery
games
are being held under a state of covert
emergency
the olympics should be a symbol of unity
and peace and you know the prime
minister said it's a simple victory
over the coming pandemic but
unfortunately it's
becoming totally opposite team gb
are games ready but the athletes aren't
going it alone
no family no friends here watching the
moments
that could define their lives they were
going to come out
so not having them here is kind of a bit
disappointing but at the same time i
think it's the right call
um i know that they're all going to be
at home watching me as it stands
375 athletes will be in the team gb
bubble and they have to maintain it as
we know
you know quick outbreaks of the covert
variant
it can bring teams down it can bring
delegations down quite quickly but
we're not in that position the hard
reality is that
nobody can guarantee how these games
will pan out
there are always problems there are
always worries before
any olympic games but this does
genuinely feel different
we know that the olympic spirit can
achieve extraordinary things
but can it overcome covid japan has been
racing to improve its slow vaccination
rate
just 20 percent of people are protected
they can't afford a super spreading
event but many fear one is just
beginning
the games are on as one olympic official
has said
only armageddon will stop it now
tom parkman's here sky news tokyo
and the luckiest man at sky news does
join us now live from
tokyo good to see you tom um of course
you will be able to watch the sport
up close and personal for those of us
like me who are just going to be
watching through the television screens
will we notice much of a difference
well you move around tokyo but you can't
really move around at the moment because
we are under very tight restrictions for
the first 14 days that we are here so
i'm on the 28th floor of our balcony at
the moment and
we can't move about freely but that is
because this situation that we are all
in this should be one of the most
exciting moments for any host nation
with all these
extraordinary human beings flying in to
show the world
what they can do but the infection rates
are over a thousand a day that's the
highest rate
in tokyo since january that is
a big deal the figures aren't as high as
we have in the united kingdom but they
are very high for japan and there is
a great deal of concern we will see
later today further protests
in tokyo still calling for the
cancellation
of the games and we know already that 30
positive cases have been picked up in
the first couple of weeks of people
coming in participants of the games
whether they are athletes or media or
part of the support staff that can that
need to be here to make an olympic games
happen well 30 cases so far
and the organizers will publish that
daily data of the number of covid cases
and i think that will be watched just as
closely as the medals table when the
sport
finally gets underway the organizers
here are walking somewhat of a tight
rope
in the next days and weeks they know
that things could change and that of
course is one of the lessons of the
pandemic isn't it we all know
how quickly things can change and
there's no reason to think why that
won't happen
in this the 32nd olympic games but
olympic games
like the kind of which we've never seen
before
tom enjoy yourselves and we'll be
speaking a lot more over the coming
weeks
thanks very much indeed uh now as we
were reporting just a couple of minutes
ago rape victims are being denied
justice because of a blame culture
between
police and prosecutors according to a
report uh from the official inspectors
let's return
uh to sky's over bennett joining us from
the newsroom either take us through this
reports
uh the culture of blame at frankly is
going to annoy an awful lot of people
here
exactly hopefully you can hear me this
time the culture of blame is what is at
the heart of
things it seems when it comes to these
low conviction rates with
police and prosecution blaming each
other for those dismally low rates that
this report talks of it also
found a more cautious attitude when it
comes to investigating and prosecuting
rape compared to other
alleged offenses and all of it means
that the collective response from the
criminal justice system as a whole in
the words of the report
often lacks focus clarity and commitment
it doesn't get much worse than that
how can things improve whether there are
several recommendations including
uh more consistent wrap around care for
rape victims campaigners are calling for
specialist training for
police and prosecutors while the report
says there is an urgent
and fun an urgent and fundamental shift
needed
in the way rape cases are handled that
call for a wholesale change though is
nothing new this report comes only a
month after the government
published its own rape review in which
it as well as apologizing to rape
victims it also
set out plans for a culture and system
change what's
new that's come to life with this report
though is this these tensions between
police and prosecution
prosecutors and until that blame culture
is
eradicated it says change is
unachievable
either many thanks indeed uh
time for us as always to check in and
see how the weather is looking as we
nudge towards the weekend
nazis standing by morning nice good
morning
lots of sunshine on the cars as high
pressure builds in and
temperatures are on their way up we
could see
highs of 30 celsius or more for the
first time this year and in fact since
september 2020
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning high pressure will be
building in and temperatures are
on their way up with plenty of sunshine
to be expected out there for the rest of
this week as well but
not everywhere across the northwest of
scotland in fact this morning it is
cloudy it's cool it's murky there's some
drizzle there
and there's a fair amount of cloud
across parts of ireland and northern
ireland as well as across some
eastern parts of england too but
elsewhere it's a mostly dry sunny and
mild start for this morning
and we'll see most of that cloud clear
away from eastern england
and there will be some good spells of
sunshine developing widely across many
areas a little bit of fair weather cloud
may bubble up across parts of ireland
northern ireland perhaps for central and
northwestern parts of england and wales
but it's fair weather club so it will
still be mainly dry and sunny across
these parts and widely warm particularly
down towards southwest but northwest
scotland cloudy cool murky and drizzly
there
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now a herd of wild asian elephants have
been caught taking time out
to have a little bit of fun uh the
adrenaline rush of
sliding down a hill proved too great for
the heart in south west china
and they've been trapped in a much
smaller area of the province so
when they got their chance they took it
whatever the cost
to the crops that they trampled
it's still to come will this year's flu
jab be part
of a covered booster program we'll be
discussing that next
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back the government will look at
reimposing
covert restrictions if the numbers of
infections continue to rise and those
case numbers become
unacceptable the solicitor general lucy
fraser was responding to comments from
england's chief medical officer
professor chris whitty who warned that
case numbers could rise surprisingly
fast when restrictions in
england are relaxed on monday we are not
by any means out of this
the woods yet on this in much better
shape due to the vaccine program
and drugs and a variety of other things
but this has got a long way to run in
the uk
and it's got even further to run
globally what we really need to do all
of us is take things incredibly slowly
i would i would reiterate that now but i
don't think we should
underestimate the fact that we could get
into trouble again
surprisingly fast
the reason why the restrictions are
being taken away is because of the
vaccination program which will protect
people when those
infection rates do rise and of course if
we get into a
situation where it's unacceptable um
and we do need to put back further
restrictions then
that of course is something the
government will look at
i don't think that the health secretary
has
suggested anything otherwise then the
infection rate is going to rise
and as a consequence of the infection
rate rising
that means because there is a link
between the two that it follows that
hospitalizations
and deaths will rise as well but there
are also consequences
to not opening up real consequences not
just to people's jobs
and the economy but to mental health as
well
also to people who haven't been going to
the doctor
because they fear it there is a
and so it is really important that we
get the balance
right as you can see joining us in the
studio our political correspondent rob
powell
morning rob do you know i'm old enough
to remember when people were describing
the relaxation taking place on monday as
irreversible yeah well it was only a few
weeks ago when sajid javid came in as
health secretary and he was very very
bullish
no going back although to be fair he was
talking about lockdowns there
but he certainly came in with a tone
that suggested that july the 19th
restrictions away maybe some guidance
but we're not going back there
essentially
the tone in a matter of a few weeks
seems to have shifted and i thought lucy
fraser almost
rowing in behind chris witty there in
terms of saying if the situation gets to
an unacceptable point
then we'll look at restrictions again
the big question though that no one
really has answered in government is
what actually is unacceptable at what
point
do hospitalizations have to reach before
they look at restrictions
how many people have to catch covert and
potentially get long covered
before they look at doing something and
all of this of course comes at a point
where we are
four days out from legal restrictions
being lifted as you pointed out hundreds
of thousands of people going to
silverstone
for the f1 this weekend so um this is a
critical point and i think
there's also a big question mark over
what exactly life looks like after july
the 19th
it is not the sort of day of freedom
parroted by some
because it's clear that medics at least
want us to
sort of ingratiate all of the rules
we've been living under for the last
15 months or so and still live by them
hands face base ventilated areas meeting
people outside
and then there's the app as well with
increasing numbers of people
being forced to stay at home even though
there are no legal restrictions on that
so i think
not quite the sort of sense of freedom
after july the 19th that some may have
hoped for
but also a big question mark about
whether in just a matter of weeks we
could be looking at restrictions again
indeed uh rob fernandez thanks very much
but as always let's
take a look at the latest set of cobit
19 data in the latest
24-hour period 48 553 new cases of
coronavirus have been reported
along with 63 more deaths now that's the
highest number
of daily deaths since april the 9th and
it takes the total
uh of people who've died within 28 days
of a positive test to
you can read it there 128 593.
i lot of vaccinations uh well just over
60 000
first jabs were given yesterday while
more than 185 000 people received their
second it means 35.3 million people
are now fully inoculated against covert
19.
as we were discussing with the solicitor
general vaccines are of course weakening
the link between infections and
hospitalizations
at the same stage in the second wave in
early autumn the ratio of cases to
hospital admissions was
three times higher than it is now and
the ratio
of cases to deaths well that was
around seven times higher
at plans for this year's flu jab program
will be unveiled later today
it's thought that the scheme could be
set up alongside a booster
for covered vaccines very pleased to say
joining us now on the program professor
adam finn
a member of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization
uh professor finn great to see you this
morning um for for those of us
with without the without the academic
qualifications that you
you possess just explain exactly why
influenza
could be such an issue this coming
autumn and winter
uh well neil the uh the the truth is
that
we we see epidemics influenza every
winter with one exception and that was
last winter the restrictions that were
in place
uh before and uh during the second wave
were sufficient to stop influenza from
being passed around
almost entirely and as a consequence of
that we actually
are really concerned that we might see a
much bigger epidemic of flu this year
simply because all of the immunity that
that epidemic would have
created it doesn't exist
so that if you have then a coincidence
of a big flu
epidemic and a further wave of covid
that doubles the pressure on the health
service and and means that we're in a
much more vulnerable place
and flu of course is not the only virus
that affects us in the winter there are
others
as well and they similarly may come back
charging in uh and cause problems
uh of course professor we will need to
wait for the announcement to know that
the specifics of the of the
the vaccination program but but in
general terms it does feel like the net
will be cast more widely there will be
more people
encouraged to take a flu vaccination
this year
than ever before for those who have not
taken one in the past but who are
perhaps
recommended to do so what advice would
you give them what what
words would you use to encourage them to
do something that they've not needed
to do before or felt that they haven't
needed to do before
uh yes i think you're right that we're
quite likely to see an extended flu
vaccine program this year
for many many years we've been offering
vaccine to the over 65s
as well as people who have uh underlying
comorbidities other illnesses that make
them more likely to get seriously ill
with flu
and we've also had a program uh in
younger children
uh children pre-school age and in
primary schools
um and we've been gradually increasing
the the age upwards of the children
who've been receiving flu vaccine so
uh i think we'll see the age the the
lower age of the elderly come down
probably to 50 years
um and also the uh the pediatric program
for kids to go up a bit
uh so in answer to your question i i
think
the one thing that we're all familiar
with now is getting vaccinated because
of the
covet vaccine and and this is really a
very similar story
flu is actually a more serious illness
than covid in some respects
certainly in children and
combined with covid it's going to cause
real problems
so the reasons for getting immunized are
to avoid getting sick with flu
and as with the cobit program to avoid
infecting your family your contacts your
work
colleagues with flu as well
so it's it's really a repeat of the
experience we've all had over the last
six months with the covid program
but with the flute program as well and i
hope what we'll see
is at least in some cases that we can
give both vaccines to people at the same
time making the whole thing more
efficient
professor i suspect a couple of people
might just have had a little choke on
their conflicts there just explain a
little bit more detail
why as you as you just said in some ways
influenza could be could be worse than
covid19
uh well we and certainly in children we
don't really see
serious illness from covet at all i mean
they can clearly get the infection but
very very few of them get seriously ill
certainly not
healthy children that's not the case for
flu actually we see
in younger children we have significant
numbers of hospitalizations and even
some deaths every year from flu
so for children flu is very definitely a
worse illness than covid
um in older people of course we don't
usually see
the the numbers of deaths that we've
been seeing
with covid but we do see thousands of
deaths every year from
influenza predominantly in older people
and to some extent in
people with underlying conditions and
that's why we have the annual flu
programme and the number of those deaths
varies quite widely from year to year
according to the strain of flu that
circulates so if we get a particularly
large and particularly bad flu
epidemic this year we could be seeing
thousands of deaths from flu
now combine that with the other viruses
and
further covered you've really got a
serious problem on your hands
a slightly different topic but of course
everything relaxes
well a lot of things relaxed come next
monday
given what we heard from chris witte
yesterday that we could find ourselves
in an awful lot of trouble you know
basically within the next
couple of months are you entirely
relaxed
about what will be taking place on
monday i can't imagine you're going
clubbing
but i'm wondering just what you think
about the broader relaxation
perhaps well perhaps you are
no i'm clubbing's not really part of my
uh lifestyle these days
um yes i i think i've been saying
consistently
that people should probably be quite
careful about the relaxation
of regulations i've been asked a number
of times
and different interviews about mask
wearing and i've been consistent in
saying that i personally will continue
to use a mask indefinitely
particularly if i have symptoms um in
order to protect other people
um uh particularly in enclosed spaces
and so on
um i think what we're hearing and seeing
here
is a readjustment in the rhetoric partly
because
of the continuing rise in number of
cases and this is a
balancing act that we've got going on at
the moment
and partly also in reflection of the
fact that it seems clear that
a quite large proportion of the public
are actually very concerned about the
relaxation
uh it's not as though everyone's
throwing their hands up with glee
and saying thank goodness it's all over
and people are
recognizing that it's not all over and
that things are
still really quite dangerous out there
so i think
there's a political readjustment to that
uh that reality and and that public
attitude
uh so i think yes things should go
carefully and we need to keep things
under control
we're still in a position of really
quite high uncertainty about what the
next few weeks holds and in the context
of uncertainty caution is always a good
approach
certainly is uh professor finn thanks so
much for joining us this morning
appreciate it
thank you now uh
time to find out what's happening in the
sport uh rob is standing by rob what you
got for us
good morning we'll already some action
for golf fans to enjoy today round two
of the open has begun
and it is a former winner who leads the
way
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
at the age of six i had meningitis
septicemia
and they said i'd never walk again my
achilles in my left leg shrunk
so that meant that sort of my knees
weren't in line with my hips so they
said that i'd constantly have problems
with that a year and a half later
i started going outside i was back
walking running
and then i got signed for qpr age eight
so
yeah there's a miracle really that i was
being able to walk and run again
how did you go from you know struggling
to walk to
be able to run around and be able to
play with the kids but the kids were
really good at football
both my legs were in plaster for about
six months
and i was in a wheelchair i can't
remember exactly how i started walking
again
but i used to have to wear like night
splints so my legs were constantly
in splints to to help me walk mentally
when i um come out of hospital i was a
vet like a different child my mom said
it wasn't the same
child that went into hospital and i had
brain damage from it
and i was on life support for six days
i've got obviously adhd i was diagnosed
um ocd and personality disorder i've got
a few
things um so that as well as
sort of playing football was a massive
sort of risk
i was lonely i felt like a very lonely
place
um with this injury now and beforehand i
was constantly
i was constantly on a high i always
thought i will get through whatever i go
through and that's that's the way i do
see it because i do whatever i go
through i do get through eventually
um and it sort of proved that i do
but i just i'm driven i'm driven to
really do well and i don't want to let
myself down
my last game i played was on the 20th of
january
2020. i've started to feel really unwell
and i felt like
my throat was swelling i remember going
to bed
and waking up and i thought i was dying
i remember sitting there on the end of
the bed
um and sort of saying
sorry it's okay
i'm saying to the nurse like my mental
health was bad
and this has really really topped it off
and she was she got sort of a woman to
come around and speak to me
um and the woman i know she was trying
to help she was saying you know
doesn't matter about football like you
you can take another journey and i
i remember sitting there thinking
committed to getting 100 million people
20
more active by 2025.
[Music]
rob thanks very much still to come on
the programme we'll be finding out how
we can support
our country's butterfly population and
the expert dr zoe randall that's next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's anger at the police under the
government
it was from this chamber the carlos
pujamon declared independence in october
i want to show other people what
happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores
but simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system
will be able to cave
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier
i have no time for any polymix
i'm tom cheshire and i'm skye's asia
correspondent based here in beijing
[Music]
[Music]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage
of life not just in childhood the pollen
reports
sponsored by phillips connected air
purifiers
plenty of sunshine is expected today and
it will be widely warm
and dry too however northwest scotland
will be cloudy with some patchy drizzle
and coastal parts of the east may remain
rather cloudy and cool
pollen levels will be high or very high
for most places today but moderate
across the north of scotland
we are currently in the peak of the
grass and spore season and weed pollen
is at a medium risk
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
now butterfly numbers have been hit hard
by
extreme weather leaving conservation
groups suggesting
that they've been badly affected by
climate change the organizers of the big
butterfly count want people across the
country
to be adding up the number that they see
in their gardens or
parks very pleased to say uh we're
joined by dr zoe randall
the senior surveys officer at butterfly
conservation and she's joining us now
from modeling hill down
nature reserve in winchester we got
there dr randall good to see you this
morning explain free viewers if we can
if you can the the thinking behind the
big butterfly count
well we want as many people as possible
to take part in the big butterfly count
which runs for the next three weeks
you simply go out and choose a sunny
spot and count the number of butterflies
you see in a 15 minute uh
15 minute period and then submit those
accounts
via the smartphone app or the website
and your data can help us
understand what's happened um to our
butterfly populations with the cold
spring that we've had
what is the current thinking as to what
is happening with the butterfly
population
we suggested a second ago that the
extreme weather conditions and indeed
climate change may be having a
having an effect
absolutely longer term populations i'm
sure that butterflies have
declined by 76 percent over us in
so that's
oh dear i think we may have a slight
problem with
like either that or uh dr randall is
very good at holding a straight face
uh we will try and re-establish the link
uh in just a second but clearly there
are issues with
the butterfly population uh let's have a
quick look and see what we can see
ah now another story we can turn our
attention to um
look away now if you haven't had your
breakfast if you're thinking of heading
for a run or heading to the gym this
morning
see if you can do better than this lot
uh
eight athletes from different countries
i put their stamina
and frankly their sanity to the test by
swimming around
70 kilometers across a near freezing
russian lake
as you can see without even the benefit
of a dry suit
the swimmers spent a total of 26 hours
in the water
and said they had originally planned a
120 kilometer relay
but the unusually cold water meant that
they had to cut their
distance uh let's see we can turn our
attention to the weather domestically
nas is standing by
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning high pressure is building
in and temperatures are
on their way up for the rest of this
week we could see temperature highs of
30 to 31 degrees celsius and it will be
the first time this year and in fact
since september 2020 that we've seen
temperatures
around 30 degrees celsius or more this
late in the season
is a little unusual the last time we had
it
late in july a temperature of 30 or more
was
back in 2014. so to begin with
we are seeing lots of sunshine out there
and it's a mild start already but
not all areas will experience the
sunshine and warmth throughout the rest
of this week in fact for the northwest
of scotland this morning it's cloudy
it's murky there's some patchy light
rain and drizzle there
fair amount of clouds still across parts
of ireland and northern ireland
particularly to the northwest
and over towards parts of east anglia
the east of kent once again
a fairly cloudy and murky morning with a
bit of drizzle likely too but
all that mostly clears away into this
afternoon revealing
lots of sunshine for most places uh for
later today
it will be feeling very warm
particularly across central south
western parts where we'd like to see the
highest temperatures with
light winds and lots of sunshine we
could see highs locally of 27 to 28
degrees celsius but widely
into the early to the mid 20s for many
parts
with plenty of sunshine except across
northwest scotland staying cloudy and
cool there
for much of today was still the risk of
some drizzle tonight it stays cloudy
uh across the northwest of scotland
still some drizzle and murky conditions
there
but cloud also drifting in across parts
of northern ireland the northwest of the
republic
and around eastern parts of england too
but in between it's mainly dry and clear
and another mild night then heading on
into the weekend
and for saturday sunny skies virtually
everywhere
another very warm day particularly
across parts of yorkshire lincolnshire
down towards the southeast of england
northwest scotland county cool and
drizzly again
and sunday is the day that we're likely
to see highs of 30 to 31 degrees celsius
hot and sunny for the south cool in the
north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways